in our ancestral environment aren't
families supposed to sleep
huddled together skin-to-skin are we
missing something important for our
health and for family cohesion
do we sleep on our belly to mimic human
contact
that's interesting um it's really hard
any such universal pronouncement is
going to be tough because there's so
much variation
that you know if you if you were in the
arctic um
probably yeah very much so um if you
are in the you know the amazon there's a
whole lot of hammock sleeping
and mostly mostly you don't sleep next
to other people because it's really
uncomfortable because it's so hot
um that's not the case i will to the
degree that there is any universal
with regard to sleep and proximity to
other human beings um for humans um it's
probably going to be about babies
right like babies and mothers definitely
sleep skin-to-skin
in pretty much i think everyone i'm just
gonna say pretty much because i'm not
totally sure but i think
i think every pre-industrial society oh
yeah
and um and you know there are a lot
there a lot of us who did that with our
own babies even though we live in you
know post-industrial societies and
um it's better for baby it's less
disruptive actually for sleep of mom
um it's it's just it's just better all
around and you know
and people and it stops at some point if
you have a if you have a strong bond
with your kid
um they don't become climate clingy and
demand that you always do the thing that
you were doing in the past yeah
in fact it creates attachment which
creates security which results in
healthy adults yeah um yeah so there are
all kinds of reasons
i would love to know if there is a
definitive review in ancestral
sleeping styles how did people actually
sleep and what does it have to do
how did they manage the parasites that
might accumulate from such a thing
um yeah you know were they sleeping on
the ground i mean
you know sleep was managed in some way
and our
current way of doing it is so novel and
has so many pathologies associated with
it
that at least knowing what people did
and in response to what environments
uh in some sort of systematic way would
be very very useful
yeah but you know for sure sticking your
newborn in a different room and letting
them scream
um as some sort of crazy ham-fisted way
to
teach them to buck up or something like
that's insane well and it comes from
this
crazy mid 20th century
flights of psychological fancy where
people thought that you you know you
were in constant danger of over
loving your children and that causing
them to
yeah that's a scourge yeah uh anyway
that stuff was all garbage
frankly if there had been anything like
an evolutionary uh
uh understanding in psychology at the
time it would have been laughed out of
the room
right children are raised to become
healthy
well-adjusted adults and adults are
built to know you know how to deploy
love to their children and the idea that
you have to inter
intervene in some counter
love right tamp down your love and you
know steal yourself to listen to your
child in the other room
screaming you must not give in and
that's just nonsense yeah i mean in fact
a lot
modern parenting um has kind of reversed
the developmental
stages at which it does the right stuff
so you know early on
you want to be in contact with your baby
as much as possible
and you know either parent both parents
other caregivers aloe parents
um and and attend to their every need as
they
as they show that they have them and
that allows you to
much more quickly than these kids who
are like isolated in rooms as babies
to they will start these you know babies
who
are who are raised from infancy uh with
with attachment
basically um you know anecdotally we
know for sure and i've seen
in research that those children are
earlier to explore
are more confident going out they they
know
that's that their parents have their
back and that you know that
that we will do everything possible for
them but that they are also now
increasingly
going to be responsible for their own
decisions they are going to have to
clean up their own messes
uh both you know physical and
psychological and social
and that actually creates anti-fragility
and um and awesomeness in in adults
in a way that um letting them scream
when they're babies and then coddling
them more and more and more as they get
older
is um asks backwards and produces
a generation that is um
that is confused and damaged and frankly
it's not really their fault
you